In general, we want to use the pooled variance since it corrects for the
different sample sizes. In the problem set, you'll get more practice using the
pooled variance. But the way the t statistic is calculated is essentially the
same. We divide the observed difference between the mean of X and the mean of Y
by the standard error, which is calculated slightly differently. Where these
guys here are this pooled variance. Note that this is the t-statistic when we
expect that the true populations that these samples come from are the same. In
other words, that the difference between the population parameters is zero.
But, say that we expect that the difference is equal to 10, for example. Then
here, we would subtract this expected difference from the observed difference
and this observed difference is what we get from our sample. So, this is our
full t-statistic for independent samples. But in general in this class, our
null hypothesis has been that there's no significant difference between the two
populations. In other words, we expect that the difference between the
parameters is about zero. There are a few assumptions to keep in mind when
using the pooled variance as there are with any method of measurement. First of
all, X and Y should be random samples from two independent populations.
Remember when we looked at dependent samples. Data coming from the same subject
twice. In this case, the population should be independent. The second, is that
the populations that X and Y come from should be approximately normal. This is
less important when the sample sizes are very large, greater than 30. A third
assumption is that the sample data can be used to estimate the population
variances and finally. The population variances should be roughly equal,
allowing us to use this pooled variance as an estimate of both.